dr. drew what should we do about John
Jones do you know about him I know a
little bit he so he just last week his
third DWI you didn't know he's gonna
have to history DUP yeah what so and as
Dumberer says there's always wiggle room
at rock bottom
I thought his rock bottom was when he
got stripped of his belt and Jimmy one
was dead you how many times and look at
him I got I used to so what do you like
ivory swing up in the ambulance so much
that it stopped being special no I just
feel like oh well john-john's every bit
of six five but my fear is you still
tears what's gonna make a predict
he's gonna end up in prison that's gonna
make him worse but here's the promise
because it happened during the corona
times this his third offense yeah do you
see what they did with an accommodator
the commuted no night in house arrest
there's nothing isn't gonna fine but
guys like that man they gotta have they
gotta fall hard they got have some real
serious car what's he fall is bigger
than life because he is you know what I
mean and so whether when reality is part
of the picture is really hard what was
the drug he was on I'll call him and
firing a gun and he was hanging out with
homeless people at 4 a.m.
homeless people one reason you do that
yeah drugs you looking for drugs and
that's where he ends this will he end up
spending more and so your problem so
let's say let's say he's housing so
let's say you're Dana White or you work
for the FC what would you do to help
John to see we can write because he said
he was going to rehab he told her home
on ii-era said this with his podcast
Daniel Cormier he goes he went to rehab
and I talked to mr. left I he owes every
summer I'm going to rehab just just
because I felt so good I'm gonna do it
every summer and he said right before he
fought Dominic Reyes which was just a
few months ago before the fight John was
drinking again which is a bad sign
before the fight he was it was before
she brought Sunday he's at in Miami
4:00 in the morning drunk yeah this is
the weekend before the fight and arrow
goes to him are you still going to Rio
me us
I don't need it anymore right here's the
problem Jones and I'm not saying this as
someone who has any expertise in this
I'm saying this as a guy who can see it
yeah and I've seen this unfortunately
too many [ __ ] times where it'd be
either an attorney
or or a someone in finance
it doesn't matter an entertainer I knew
personally some people are too talented
for their own good
yeah what I said on Jones oh and the
most people if not all people in the
light would have light heavyweight
division without training at all but he
still he's barely getting by now Pete
these guys because because some people
thought he lost his last fight some
people say let's fly please
yeah Qing buy so you think he'd like
alright I'm a [ __ ] but I need to get
it someone in control cuz I'm close to
losing maybe I have a close friend of
mine who's a world-class grappler who
wouldn't he and I kind of got cleaned I
know yeah but he's not open about his
struggle so I'm trying to did he fight
too no just just grappling but he said a
DCCC champion and he and I kind of got
cleaned together and he and I care about
each other very much and he had a lot of
struggles early on because he could
literally stay up all night smoke four
packs of cigarettes hit that hit a
couple bumps on the way to the mats and
crush every so and because I I I could
look at it and go I literally had
nowhere to go I was I was in a hotel in
Inglewood with at day time watching
Jenny Jones [ __ ] hit tin foil made a
little tin foil up I think and I and I
just ruck one [ __ ] look at myself in
the mirror and I was like oh this
there's nowhere to go
yeah I can die or I can do something and
that was it and seeing yourself for
yourself as your are is often these
moments of clarity so you've got to have
that but Mike's point is well-taken that
these guys that have lots of power lots
of money incredible ability lots of
trauma growing up lots of narcissism and
lots of drug addiction and biology very
hard things you I don't chop to him dr.
Giorno I've told for what I'd be wanting
someone like that spent two years away
he's what you don't hear that you had
two years away that's what he means two
years away in treatment two years away
from the sport
cheers away from my so he's not fighting
for a year is that what he'll he'll
fight this year well yeah I thought were
the you know that there was so certain
okay that hasn't
is he allowed to fight in terms of the
judge giving him this is a month okay
he's so the US he could fight labs give
him a fight in November
he's not gonna do anything to our show
that's the other thing is the UFC's
they're playing they're playing ball as
long as they can with jaunt course a
Dilla T that's the Bell doesn't play
that game not not as no hole to hold up
doctor not as much like Antonio Brown
like we just used to do we can we
[ __ ] can't he's no different than
Antonio Brown that the the biggest
problem I had with any celebrity
performer musician was that they were
broke going back to Bert work to
prematurely and they made so much money
and the people around them wanted to
them to do it it was always always what
can also to stick up for entertainers
and athletes there's a famine mentality
about your work if you're a great
attorney or your great banker your great
electrician you can always go back to
your work when you everything is you
know like if you look if you're a comic
or an athlete a fighter every [ __ ]
day away from you're like I'm losing my
career yeah I saw that firsthand with a
certain actor who was making a group of
people a lot of money and he had a spin
out on cocaine Beyond and I remember his
Asian I've heard him say don't worry
don't worry we'll get him we'll get him
sober and back to India Jesus you've I
remember it so well I was like this is
LA I was like fine guess what happened
to him he spiraled even worse but it of
course you would think with John at some
point because this is third of fancies I
think he's at for now you think someone
in his nucleus his team would go dude
with whatever doings not work he he will
he will start to jettison anybody that
gets in the way of his music them out
yeah he was Gabriel and so yeah I just
used you he'll do eventually he'll have
a ring of insular people that you know
just keep him getting such a shame yeah
that's what I think about too much
talent for zone good is because also
people like that they can create a world
where they don't have peers yeah because
you know like realistically John can
justifiably go into Jackson wake and be
like I don't know you yeah I don't need
buddies I don't need a party with you I
don't
- bro out but guys aren't there aren't
there drugs that can keep you off
alcohol aren't there drugs you can take
yeah it'd allow you to have one drink
than just alcohol yeah so so but there's
two basic sort of zones of pharmacology
in this one is in L trek zone which for
some people really reduces their desire
to drink and they sort of reward they
get from it but you're talking about an
abuse which makes people sick if they
drink yeah and guess what they do if if
they want to drink they don't eat the
[ __ ] abuse or if they have an abuse
implant or stuff that they chew it out
of their arms I've seen that seriously
oh yeah I've also seen [ __ ] I'm also
seeing someone I wouldn't call my friend
but a quaint ins who got on antabuse and
just took up pills and smoking when you
switch smoking weed and eating pills all
day yeah I don't know what you do with
John I've no idea it's gonna play out
it's gonna have to play out how it plays
out I don't know that anybody has any
controller I guess the only things
sometimes for some people is like you we
always say death or bottom and bottom me
out and bottoming out is really bad I
thought John hit his bot with his rock
bottom we hit that lady and she was
pregnant and she broke her arm and he
went back and got the cash and they
strimmers title and spent it for two
years I was like that's rock bottom for
that man nope
how was he 32 also drug addiction when
he's 42 how bad it's gonna get I'm not
making I'm not making excuses for John
in any way but drug addiction changes
you it turns you into a person that you
don't like being you commit you and you
turn into a criminal or maybe not even
aware of the fact that he's changed so
to add this and do it - doctor might add
in CT you're crazy if you don't think
this is also CT mix on top of the
interest addiction because they release
the footage of him being stopped off the
DWI and the cop goes I want you to do
this this and this and he goes I'm just
gonna tell you my short-term memories
bad I get punched in the face my short
term I guess oh I know you're gonna
think I'm drunk which he is he was but a
drunk or not my short-term memory is
awful from fighting and you're like oh
that's not good oh good and you hear the
cop less there's him over here I go [ __ ]
what if he just turns on me oh this guy
wants a visca this is the same cops pull
him over two or three times so once
there's a bad
there's underlying mental illness here -
of something nothing whether it's mood
disorder bipolar is is that typically in
is that typically a sister to this yeah
I made it both by whatever you've done
to yourself and wherever you've gone
with your drug addiction um however
you've affected your brain with the
drugs that you're using you can
precipitate a mental illness by trauma
is sort of a typical and inciting
influence of addiction and trauma has
its own set of mental health can I ask
you this I've seen this - well you see
somebody who's totally fine most of the
time and then they go on spurts or they
have like or though so they'll be
totally normal for two weeks and then
they'll take three days and be complete
[ __ ] rat binge alcoholics yeah what
is that about that they're they're a
special group the binge users there and
they're tougher to treat because they
convince themselves they can control it
yeah because they kind of do yeah right
I'm gonna do it I'm not gonna do that
again
oh yeah yeah I learned my lesson this
but then they it gets really bad boom it
happens III don't want to confuse people
with what Brian's talking about like
it's super real don't confuse that with
like I'm a normal dad and I work hard
and then every three weeks I go to Vegas
and do a couple bumps a blow no that's
no we're talking about you go from zero
to 1 million babies that the thing is is
with those people they can say all they
want and and they're full of [ __ ] during
those three weeks they're white nuts so
not to go back to Spencer Tracy
Katherine Hepburn and hurt that boy he
said he was one of the movie stars grow
back he would she knew cuz he would
check into a hotel he would disappear he
checking all the tile get in a bathtub
put a [ __ ] towel around his neck and
drink for three days until he just
passed out he would do it right in the
bathtub so he could hose off pee
whatever she would come to his hotel
room and sleep at the foot of his bed
and just wait for him to go through that
[ __ ] box right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah watch your tongue oh good what's
gonna happen what are you gonna do use
some of that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]